hey Vsauce Michael here and today we're
going to discuss deja vu what is it and
why does it occur you know those moments
where the current situation feels like
it's happened before you're certain it
has but you don't know when or how it
became so familiar it's difficult to
scientifically study deja vu because
there's no reliable way to cause it to
happen in people's heads in a laboratory
but here's what we do know humans don't
seem to experience deja vu until they're
at least eight or nine years old it's
most frequent in your teens and 20s and
then tapers off as you get older so it
might have something to do with brain
development in fact we should probably
go get ourselves a brain that was easy
now like a stomachache deja vu may be a
symptom with many possible causes a lot
of the popular theories about what
causes it involve a disconnect that may
be occurring between the deep structures
of the brain that process our
experiences unconsciously and the parts
of the brain that are conscious of what
we experience process it and then tell
us what we're seeing for the sake of
simplicity let's begin with the visual
system now the brain sits in your head
like this and your eyeballs are over
here seeing things sending that signal
to the back of the brain the occipital
lobe where visual cortex is that's where
the image is processed and we become
aware of what we're seeing but visual
cortex isn't the first stop that
information makes instead we know that
it stops and lots of other places for
instance the amygdala where it may be
processed at an involuntary emotional
level and this fun little part right
here number 31 the tectum it's involved
in preliminary visual processing and
helps control eye movements now that
fact is incredibly important because
what it means is that people with
blindness caused by brain damage to the
visual cortex cannot see anything they
don't report seeing or recognizing
anything however the other preliminary
parts of the brain that get that message
are still healthy and so despite being
legally blind these people exhibit what
is known as blind sight they can defy
all odds and avoid an obstacle course on
the ground they can also be presented
faces showing joy
or anxiety and fear and feel without
knowing why at all on earth they feel
that way a similar emotion so a lot is
going on when we look at things and if
those preliminary structures in the
vision system allow certain blind people
to be oddly and unconsciously aware of
what they're looking at we may have the
ingredients we need for this disconnect
think of it this way if I experienced
event a and then B and then C and the
inner parts of my brain committed to
memory and generate an emotional
response but then a fraction of a second
later out of sync my visual cortex
finally gets around to telling me the
conscious aware part of my brain what
I'm seeing it'll say okay guys we're
looking at a and then B and then and the
brain says whoa we'll wait wait and then
C right I mean we already that's already
happened I thought we'd say and that may
be deja vu but what could cause these
processes dealing with the same
information to get temporarily out of
sync like that well it's probably a
neurological abnormality possibly an
epileptic episode where neurons all fire
in sync we also know that patients who
experience chronic and persistent deja
vu tend to have brain damage in the
temporal lobes of their brain these
lobes on either side well that sounds
kind of bad right I mean when I
experience deja vu' should I run to the
doctor right away well not at all in
fact minor epileptic events are quite
common you've probably experienced a
similar phenomenon known as a hypnagogic
jerk that's a fancy name for what occurs
when you're about to fall asleep and
that all of a sudden you feel like
you're falling or that you tripped and
your body jolts itself awake what's
going on there is that as you fall
asleep your muscles relax and some part
of your brain that's still awake notices
that and feels like you're no longer
supported you must be falling and it
sends out a huge signal that causes all
of your muscles to twitch waking you up
oh and deja vu is not the only boo out
there there's also something known as
press que vous or tip of the tongue and
this is what happens when you're
familiar with something you know you
know it but for the life of you at that
moment you cannot
call it it's like what's that actor's
name from that movie I've seen it 18
times how can I not remember it Wow one
explanation of how that happens is that
other words similar to the target word
are being remembered and to help you out
your brain is actively blocking other
stuff around it including the word
you're actually looking for now this
explanation is really nice because it
might help explain why press gave ooh
has a shared or social aspect even a
bunch of people in a group all with
separate brains if they're given the
same blocking words that are related no
one in the group can come up with the
name until the subject is changed and
those words are no longer blocked and
then all of a sudden someone goes oh
Gary Sinise that's who it was
yeah there you go okay finally Jame vu
this is when something that you know
something that you're familiar with all
of a sudden seems brand new and bizarre
schizophrenic patients will sometimes
see people they know and insist that
it's not the person they know instead
it's an imposter but all of us have
probably experienced Jame vu to a
certain extent for instance when you
repeat a word over and over and over and
over and over and over again the word
starts to lose its meaning and you start
to think what how is this even a word
it's so weird well scientists believe
that happens because continuing to
excite the neurons responsible for that
word causes them to become inhibited and
further use is less intense it's just
crazy to think that there's so much out
there in the world in the universe that
we don't know that we don't understand
that we haven't yet discovered but yet
that very feeling of familiarity for
what we do know can't always be trusted
about the only constant seems to be as
always thanks for watching